in the lobby of Ramsey solutions Chris
and Amanda are with us hey guys how are
you welcome welcome good to have you
where do you live here in Nashville
oh we're neighbors then very cool God
and here to do your debt-free scream
right here in the lobby the last people
were from Alaska you come across yeah
you come across town yeah I love it so
how much of your bed just over 53,000
good for you and how long did that take
three and a half years good and making
what range of income during that time
eighty to ninety very good what do you
guys do for a living and I work at
Lipscomb University I manage one of the
recruiting teams up there cool
very good and good for you guys very
neat
so what kind of debt was this fifty
three thousand dollars that would all be
on my student loans
ugly sister Sallie Mae okay oh my
goodness I love you two been married
radio we've never lost a patient yet
okay so about the time you got married
you'd look up and say all right we're
gonna work on a man to student loans so
how did that conversation take place
well it started pretty quickly even when
we were engaged Chris knew that I had
the student loans and he had no debt and
you know that was his plan all along so
when we got engaged his parents actually
sent us to Financial Peace University we
talked about premarital counseling I
think I was finishing up my Master's
when we got married
what's your master's in education good
for you so pretty quickly after that was
wrapped up we knew we were gonna nip it
in the bud
very cool very good so Chris did you
grow up with this stuff or something if
your parents did financial piece and you
did I mean they bought it for y'all or
they suggested and you had no debt so
when I was the junior in high school
they went through the plan
and they had about the same amount of
debt and they knocked it out and so
obviously they knew about her student
loans and one must be on the right track
and Amanda did that feel like the like
the in-laws were ganging up on you or
anything no I I would say we I agree but
grew up pretty conservatively I mean my
parents were frugal always saving and
coupons but student loans were kind of
just a normal thing if you're if you're
gonna go to college that's you know
going to be part of it so we're we
weren't racking up any other kind of
debt and student loans was kind of just
the thing that everyone had right so I
definitely didn't feel you know like
they were ganging up on me I know it was
something that needed to be done okay
all right they were just helping that's
good that's good what a great spirit
that's wonderful very fine okay so you
got married student loans are laying
there and we finish up the masters and
then we get in attack mode and start
knocking on these debts as fast as you
can what was the hardest part for you to
cuz you're brand-new married couple
attacking this for me I'm definitely a
spender and when I got that first salary
out of college it was pretty quick to go
shopping and eating out and all that you
know so cutting back on the shopping and
entertainment and all that that was that
was a big change for me and to get used
to you and I don't know if it's ever
really gotten easy to do that well not
you know I'm a dad it loosens up a lot
right you know and so what about you
Chris was the hardest part of this for
you I'd say obviously just sticking to
it because obviously you get a lot of
pool from friends or family or wanting
to go to this and that and it's like you
have to stay true to the budget and know
that you have a bigger goal in mind
yeah the nose you have to say no a lot
yeah yeah you have to learn that learn
that word a lot for a lot of different
things and so forth so advice tip from
you too I mean your your old married
people now I mean so it's four years so
there's a young couple out there that's
engaged that's listening this they got
$50,000 in student loan debt
between them or one of them does and
what's your advice to them and I would
say obviously it was it was harder for
me and being a spender we did the
envelopes and they worked really well
for us and I've heard a lot of people
say that the envelopes didn't work for
us
but I think if you just communicate
and if maybe the saver will have some
flexibility we definitely had some some
cries at our dinner table will have me
saying you know I was upset about not
having enough money or you know whatever
that was me but he was always very
flexible and we would move money around
from this envelope to that envelope and
it just you know the open communication
was a huge part for us cool Chris I say
stick to it and yet they decide what you
really want and you know because as soon
as you put the pen to the paper or hop
on every dollar life's gonna hit you in
the mouth and you have to make that
decision like I you know this is it like
we're going all-in at it there you go
that's it
was it Muhammad Ali said everybody talks
good till somebody hit you in the mouth
yeah that's it all of a sudden it
changes everything then you know when
you when you put the numbers down there
you go whoa this is life this is real we
got to do this well congratulations you
tanked I'm very proud of you're very
well done no debt at all the student
loan is gone I love it very very fun all
right we're gonna give you a copy of
Chris Hogan's new book retire inspired
it's a number one bestseller that's the
next chapter in your story because
you're heroes in a story man I'm proud
of you and now you now you don't any
payments and now you know how to handle
money and now you know how to handle it
together as a married couple you are so
far ahead of most people out there
walking around right the second and that
puts you in a position to build wealth
and to be outrageously generous to your
Sam very cool place very proud of you
guys good job Chris and Amanda from
Nashville fifty three thousand dollars
paid off in three and a half years
making eighty to ninety thousand count
it down let's era debt-free scream three
two one we're dead
love it
way to go you two very very well done
man life is good and that's just awesome
stuff right there hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show